here's what we need more of we need one
or two more to be bought look at what
Spotify did the best thing with Spotify
you guys have no idea how big of a role
Spotify played a year ago with Joe Rogan
when everybody was saying cancel cancel
Joe Rogan with a Spotify a company out
of Sweden Sweden yeah and they said yeah
yeah no we're not going to cancel it not
doing it what do you mean we're not
going to cancel him 2018 was the
September 13th the video went out but
the interview was on 9 11. yeah I'm not
canceling them you're not canceling no
we're not going to cancel Joe Rogan so
everybody was hoping if
if Spotify I cannot tell you guys how
big of a role Spotify played in the
concept of cancel culture if Spotify
would have said no we are going to
cancel Joe Rogan let me tell you
massively problematic for a lot of
people in America
[Music]
[Applause]